hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar quality control processes for
accurate and reliable microbial next
generation sequencing i'm susie valdez
of lab roots and i will be your
moderator for today's event today's
educational web seminar is presented by
labyrinth and brought to you by
microgendx to learn more visit them at
microgendx
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you might have
during this presentation to do so simply
type them into the ask a question box
and click send we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation you may also submit
any technical issues here as well if you
have any trouble seeing or hearing this
presentation this webinar is educational
and thus offers free continuing
education credits please click on the
continuing education credits window at
the bottom of your screen to obtain
those credits i'd now like to welcome
our speaker dr jose alexander a clinical
and technical director of microbiology
biology and immunology laboratories at
the advent health in orlando dr
alexander welcome you may now begin your
presentation sir
well thank you very much especially
thanks to microgndx for allowing me to
do this presentation today we're going
to talk about quality control process
for accurate reliable microbial next
generation sequencing and this is
important since ngs is becoming a
leading technology for diagnostic
infection disease but especially making
sure that the technology is reliable and
is accurate is part of the whole quality
assurance and quality control process
that we need to have and especially
before
during the introduction of this new
technology
as a disclosure i'm a speaker and
consultant for microgndx
and the top the the the topic that we're
going to discuss today is why is ngs
relevant for modern microbiology the
important quality control consideration
for ngs setup
and interpreting ngs plus biomarkers
especially in the area of orthopedic
results and this is one area that is
actually complementing the ngs
especially since ngs were sold by itself
could be a little difficult to interpret
the high sensitivity of the assay itself
so the use of biomarkers can help to
clarify those
results that are probably no completely
clinically
clear about the outcome and the clinical
significance of those results
before to start it's important to
mention the ngs can complement culture
improve and also can provide an
improvement in diagnostic infection
disease
we know that the current
culture has some limitations
intracellular bacteria nutritionally
nutritionally challenging organisms
fastidious organism and also antidotes
those are organic bacterial um
organisms that require special media to
grow they also require spatial
environmental conditions
um and some of them will never grow in
routine microbiology culture so
technically right now the microbiology
culture is just limited for whatever can
growth in the media and it can grow in
the condition that we provide in the
laboratory
the complementing traditional culture
with ngfs can also facilitate a rapid
turnaround time compared with roma
culture if we have a sample that we see
organism and a gram stain
and normally it will take 24 hours or a
little more to grow and to be able to
identify
with ngs we're going to be able to have
this rapid identification
directly from the sample
identify organism that is excluded by
culture how we mentioned before
intra-cellular organisms organisms that
are nutritionally challenging especially
those that
are not considered during the setup of
the culture can also be identified by
ngs and one of the areas that is
probably the most important is with
mycobacterius and fungi
we know the afb can take up to eight
weeks
to grow and fungi culture are normally
kept in the incubator up to four weeks
having ngs able to identify
mycobacterius and also fungi can
facilitate and provide a rapid
identification in just a matter of few
days three four or five days compared
with traditional culture
the other advantage is that having a
positive smear in the case of
microbacteria a fluorescence meter or
phil nielsen or as this is
a specific fungi smear
they are positive to direct observation
beside the culture ngs could also be
performed and have a wrap identification
of this organism using
one of the gold standard in this case
that is the ngs
but the quality control that the ngs
implementation required a good quality
control and this quality control and the
whole implementation can be um described
in a serious step one is the
implementation itself
we need to have a validation process and
we have to have a a database that is
reliable so before to start with
implementation before the start with the
with the with the validation itself we
need to make sure that the database that
we are using for identifying this
organism detector in the sample is
reliable is accurate and the the
sequence that are present in the
database are being able to be analyzed
and be proved that are able to identify
the right organism
and then come the validation process
that we unders we know that there is a
different type of validation process
depending if it's a validation itself or
is a verification
the sample testing we need to have
processes that are pre in the analytical
step in the analytical and in the post
analytical step we have to have consider
the importance of the quality of the
sample
ngs like any other microbiology method
require a high quality sample and we
need a sample that is representative
again ngs is highly sensitive if we are
not careful with the type of sample that
we analyze we can be introducing
organisms contaminant or even normal
flora organism that can make the
interpretation of the resolution to be
challenging
the laboratory process they should be
able to guarantee that there is no
inclusion of any contaminant during the
analytical process especially during the
setup process of the sample
we have to have a strong bioinformatic
analysis that is able to analyze the
whole all the result coming from the
sequencing and being able to put in a
result as a post analytical step that is
clinically significant if this is only
ngs or if it's a result that is done in
conjunction with um by biomarkers
and then we also have to have an ongoing
quality assurance process proficiency
testing is critical every laboratory
that is a client certified
need to be
enrolled in a proficiency testing a
program and this requires that specimen
arriving to a standardized pro specimen
arriving to the laboratory can be run
and it can be proved that the method is
reliable and is able to identify the
organism present on the specimen
so
when we talk about
ngs we in this presentation we're
specifically talking about targeted ngs
and this is the ngs that target the 16s
ribosomal rna genes those are genes that
are in the in the
in the bacterial chromosome that um
codify for the ribosomal rna
and the idea to target this region is
that they are highly con
conserved genes
and they actually also have some nine um
hypervariable regions that can allow us
to identify different genomes but also
species of organism
one of the um advantage to target genes
is that allow us to
target with specific set of primers this
gene amplify the pres
the products of this
pcr this amplification and that can
increase the amount of
sequence from microbial dna when we
compare with the host
dna how we know when we run sequencing
directly for patient sample we have a
lot of dna from the host and this dna
has become an interference during the
process so targeting um ngs targeting
these regions allow us to increase the
amount of these genes uh uh um and i
mean
when we consider that in relationship
with with the host dna
it's a little bit easier to perform the
the
the sequence and identify the organism
um there is um nine hypervariable
regions but the region one or two as the
one that has the best identification for
human pathogens the same happened for
fungi we have the internal transcriber
spaces and they are also part of the
ribosome of genes
and those are regions that allow to
identification of yeast but also molds
are able to identify the genus and also
the species for this group of organisms
but it's also important to consider
during implementation that there could
be a lack of resolution of
discrimination between species when we
use 16s and also when we use ips for
fungi
the best example is when we have e coli
and shigella
those genes are those two organisms have
very similar and genetically speaking
and some of the sequences are unable to
differentiate these two species so the
way to differentiate them is to develop
a set of primers that is able to be used
not only as a qualitative process but
also to differentiate between species
that are close related where the ngs is
having the most uh technically um
challenging to differentiate an example
of that is creating a primer for e coli
or primary fortuigela when the ngs
detect e coli or chiguela the pcr can
solve that discrepancy and that can only
happen with this organism but also
including with microbacterias and fungi
one of the important thing with 16s is
that it's not only for gram-positive and
negative bacteria we are also able to
identify
uh partial asymptotes and also
microbacteria any other um um um
including afv
tuberculosis mycobacterium tuberculosis
so
before the implementation is very
important to have clear what is target
the gene that we're going to be able to
identify and then based on that being
able to have a database that is accurate
and is reliable at this level
so
an accurate bacterial fungi sequence is
important at this moment so with um that
is the reference sequence that we can
find the national center for
biotechnology informatica or ncbi it's
an open access a public library that we
can find a sequence of
of nucleotides that can identify
different organisms the bacterial cell
fungi of fungi but it's important that
when we take that data that information
from the database we are able to review
and remove those sequences that are
incomplete or those that have taxonomic
information that are incorrect this is a
public database
it's important to have in consideration
the quality of those sequences that are
in the public database since we can have
some incorrect and incomplete sequence
in this database
we have to remove low quality reits also
in those regions that are important for
us to target if we targeted the v1 and
v2 region we need to make sure that the
quality of those reads are high enough
and and good enough to even correctly
identify the species that we're looking
for
and we also need to eliminate inaccurate
matching species if we have some
sequence that is being published for a
specific organism but when we test those
sequence and are not able to identify
the organism that actually they describe
we need to make sure that those
inaccurate um sequence are removed
one of the important things something
that we are used to in the laboratory
using atcc strains and this is a
valuable source for also verify some of
those sequence if we have an
atcc strain for specific genomes of
species we can run the sequencing and
compare that against the sequence that
is public in the database
and for the validation process so we
know that we have a validation and also
a verification process so what we
understand in the micro laboratory as a
test verification is those are fda clear
and approve methods we require
analytical accuracy analytical precision
and reportable range and this is part of
the cap checklist the com 4300
but when we i'm trying to implement an
ngs we are implementing a lab developed
test there is no an fda clear
a platform or fda clear up process to be
able to implement
ngs for clinical purposes there is work
being done in that direction is
hopefully in the future we're going to
be able to have some platform and some
process and tests available that will be
fda approved and that will simplify the
process of verification but in the
process of validation we need to include
also besides the same three
characteristics for the verification
we need to include
analytical sensitivity analytical
specificity and also any other
performance characteristics that require
that we can include their interference
substances
that is that probably would be one of
the most significant based on the type
of samples that we are um intended to
use for the ngs and the clinical setting
and this is for the cap checklist com 40
350 and that can be found in the all
common chapters
one of the first step for sequencing and
something that we need to reinforce and
make sure that there is
is is probably a highly critical
information that need to be transmitted
to clinicians is the sample collection
ngs like any other laboratory results
require a high quality sample and this
is critical we need to make sure that
the specimen that is collected is
representative of the deletion of the
representative of the area that we're
trying to rule out the process on
infection we need to make sure that
there is no contaminant for normal flora
or any other um during the process of
collection
it is important to consider too if there
is a suspicious typical organism that
we're looking for that we are able to uh
to call example for the right um
source so in this example we have a
joint infection so we can collect sample
um
as a synovial fluid we can have um
scraps from from any
joint prosthesis um we can also get
samples directly from the intra canal
from the bone or we can collect tissue
so
all those high quality samples are
critical and if the specimen is now
collected with careful and the specimen
is contaminated with surrounding
microbiome those organisms can be
present on the final result and they can
provide a little difficult uh difficulty
to the clinician to be able to
differentiate which of these organisms
could be a real pathogen of which of
them could be just a normal flora floral
colonizer so
sample collection sample quality is
highly important and this is a
responsibility for the provider and for
the um
the clinician that is requesting the ngs
to make sure to to provide a high
quality sample and the laboratory can
then provide the rest of the high um um
skillful technique to make sure that we
don't introduce any contaminants during
the the analytical process in the
laboratory
[Music]
so we have um to to ensure a high
quality and reliability of ngs that is
multiple controls um there are
that are being introduced during the
whole process of ngs during the dna
extraction we have internal and positive
and negative control that are introduced
to guarantee that the dna is extracted
from the specimen
we have three levels of control during
the sequencing we have a high medium and
a low positive control and we also have
a negative control this guaranteed that
the the different level of of of
concentration of the dna are able to be
analyzed and recognized and all and also
detected but in the same time this also
guarantee that the instrument is working
at the limit of detection that is
expected
we have environmental controls that are
set up during the process but also
something that in laboratory we know as
a swipe test the environment the
equipment are routinely test to look for
some potential contaminants from the
environment and this environment these
contaminants or these organisms present
in the environment are recognized the
laboratory key tracker them and those
are taking consideration when the test
is performed and the result is obtained
from the from the sequence because those
environmental organisms
some of them are prevalent in the
environment and we need to make sure
that we are recognizing them and we know
the level that they are normally in the
bottom and then we have a bioinformatic
pipeline we have pre-analytical
denoising and also diversity analysis so
it's important that all the clinical the
digital data coming from the sequence is
a properly analyzed
the noise coming from this data is clear
and we can use this data then when the
um the quality is acceptable to start
assigning um organism based on the
sequence that were detected
so the target ngs we also have the
amplification in cell is a process for
quality assurance so
all the samples there are batched
together they are barcoding so we have a
specific sequence of known dna that are
attached to every
sample every dna for every sample
um that also when we have an
amplification of this target genes that
are the 16s
where they allow us to remove or in
relative terms to remove the human dna
by amplifying the microbial at target
and also we have a gel electrophoresis
for size selection and quality control
we make sure that the size of this
sequence that will be analyzed are able
to have the quality and the size that is
appropriate for the platform that is
being used for sequence
and this is important that every
laboratory that is implementing ngs
recognize what is the the requirement
for each of those ngs
sequencer platform to make sure that the
the quality and the size of the sequence
actually match what they ever
recommended by the manufacturer
so we have a niche plate especially when
we set up a plate it's important that
it's important that we are able to set
three levels of positive control low
medium high but also have a negative to
be able to evaluate the possible
potential in inclusion of contamination
during the process
so when the the data all the information
come from this the sequencer when the
sample is is
is runs in the sequencer all that
clinica that take a digital data is now
going to the import bioinformatic
pipeline so we have a pre-analytical
denoising and diversity and nice
analysis
and then bioinformatics quality control
we use the threat quality score the
insurance that we have a 99.9 call and
this is something around one in 10 000
errors in a nucleotide in a sequence so
we're talking about that we are um
[Music]
analyzing um fragments of dna around 300
400
base pairs so one error in 10 000 base
pairs is what is acceptable so we're
talking about one error in multiple
um
a multiple fragments so it's a very
minimal error that is that is acceptable
during the sequence um
and then that if that actually will pass
the quality control of the digital data
to be able to get into any
bioinformatics and analysis
chemera detections um during the
amplification of these 16s genes there
could be some mismatching or or
some amplification that stopped earlier
some applications that can actually
combine different amplification
fragments and they give some chimera
this camera are
detected during the process of before to
be able to assign organism to be able to
avoid errors so the chimera is important
to be able to remove those
false positive organisms
to able to provide an accurate on the us
on the
assigning
genus and also species to the organism
that are detected
also sequence that don't meet the size
selection criteria those sequence of a
fragment of dna that don't meet the
criteria for the sequencer or they are
smaller than what is expected they can
be removed from the analytical um
step of the sequencer also um any
sequence they have an error not only
during the in the fragment of the gene
that was sequenced but also in the
adapter that were attached during the
specimen processing or even on the
barcoding those are also removed
so from the post analytical and
reporting we make sure
that when the the all bioinformatics
pipeline is analyzing the data the
quality controls are resolved as
expected the negative traction control
is also as expected and there was no
introduction of any contaminants there
is no template control that means
that those um a blank sample that were
introduced in the batch they are
negative there was no introduction of
contamination during the process this
guaranteed that every
organism report from a sample actually
came the organism is actually present in
the sample and was not introduced by the
laboratory during the process
um each um
[Music]
we also there has to be a review of each
report and looking for any potential
contaminants if there is a trend of some
organisms that are present in multiple
results those have to be reviewed and
those sequences that are unique those
sequence that are not present or those
sequence that are not matching any order
on the by for any other reference in the
bio and the bioinformatics um pipelines
they need to be
investigated so there is there is an
automated uh quality control process
that happen in the bioformatic pipeline
but it's also a manual review that is
done by an operator in this case a
molecular technologist that is able to
review each of those results coming from
the sequencer before to be
released in a report so this is a very
strong and robust process not only from
the moment that the specimen arrives
during the analysis and in the
biopharmatic pipeline so the whole
process is to guarantee that the
specimen that we are receiving for
analysis for ngs the result that we are
reporting is actually from organism
present in the specimen so those
organisms were not introduced in any
point during the pre-analytical
analytical or it wasn't any error during
the bioinformatics pipeline so the
laboratory need to be able to provide an
accurate reliable
result
i'm trusting that
the sample that will receive is a high
quality sample and the organism present
are clinically significant
also a part of part of to keep
ngs
implemented in the clinical setting it's
important to be enrolled in a
professional testing there is multiple
organizations that provide proficiency
testing programs they are blind and
samples as a laboratory and
you are very familiar with the
proficiency testing of pt
samples they are blind the sample every
laboratory be able
need to be able to test
um multiple times a year and also um and
there is some inter agreement between
laboratories when the result is released
by this organization
they compare against each other and see
how well
you were able to perform and this is
important to have as part of the quality
assurance process this is also to
guarantee that that we are no
introducing contaminants we're actually
able to identify
the organisms that are present in the
sample and we are able to report or able
to do what we are expecting to do
and make sure that the whole process not
only have a high quality standard but
also is clinically significant when we
report
one of the important
areas currently for ngs is the use of
biomarkers
in the example with a microgen dx result
um that is an ngs plus biomarkers and
this is offered for orthopedic results
and in the 2008 international consensus
a meeting
um that was able to introduce the ngs as
part one of the criteria especially
one of the pre-operative diagnostic um
sorry one of the interpreters is
diagnostic we can see that there is
multiple
multiple criterias for um for calling
a a
prosthetic joint infection we have minor
criteria that use biomarkers and assign
a possible possible score and every
patient when we assign the score and we
have a possible decision making so in
the section that we have um um when we
have the property score we have the
positive
um histology the culture and we also
have a positive ngs all of them have a
possible score and that give a patient a
score that gives you a community patient
score
that can
provide a
a probability of infection so in this
case we are giving the clinician not
only
a positive ngs indicating yes that is
organism present example but we also
given the clinician a probability of
infection that is based on biomarkers
that is an indicative of how the patient
immune response or how the patient the
host in this case is reacting to
the the the
the condition that is happening on the
joint if this is a real infection or is
not if the organism present came from a
good quality sample collected and this
is translated with a good with a with a
call by the ngs but also with positive
biomarkers all the organisms and presses
on the ngs
are significant but the biomarkers are
negative so the combination of these two
characteristics plus the clinical
perspective that the clinician has can
provide a probability of infection so
the future of ngs with biomarkers seems
to be a
a route that can facilitate the
implementation and also the
interpretation of the ngs resolve for um
being to decide the significance of some
of the lesion and it does
with the probability of infection in
those areas
so in summary next generation sequencing
play a complementary role for infection
this is diagnostic and also possible
food management there is multiple
processing guarantee accuracy and
reliability a good value validation
process a construction of a verified
sequence a good database the importance
of the quality sample of collection this
is critical as a laboratory especially
as a microbiologist we know that we need
to have a good quality sample any good
results start for a good quality sample
and we need to follow this ngs and even
make an even more
um
even stricter than
regular cultures a laboratory process to
avoid and detect contamination is part
of the quality management system and is
also critical to be able to keep the
high quality bioinformatic analysis we
have to have a pipeline that's automated
and is able to identify um any deviation
quality control and also any errors and
the post analytical reporting is always
important to have a human factor to be
able to review results
and trying to identify some variation
that the automated system are not able
to the proficiency testing is also
critical to make sure that the process
continue as we intended to be to be used
and the
as part also of a clinical
implementation as being a clia certified
laboratory
and again the biomarker for interpreting
ngs um especially in infection
diagnostic seems to be playing an
important role and this is a section an
area that could continue expanding to
not only on prosthetic joint infection
but also from any other source of
infection and and can facilitate
especially to clinician to trying to
adjudicate probability of infection
based on ngs and biomarkers
so
and and this way i i finished my
presentation and now we're going to have
a section of questions
um if you have any specific question
about this process i will be happy to
answer thank you very much
thank you dr alexander for that
informative presentation we will now
start the live q and a portion of the
webinar if you have any questions you
want to ask please do so now just click
on that ask a question box located on
the far left of your screen and we'll
answer as many questions as we have time
for
and it looks like we already have some
great questions coming in
our first question that we
got from our audience is
culture methods grow whatever organism
is in the sample why is there a need for
ngs when culture can already identify
the infecting organism
well first of all we know that
organizing the growing culture are those
that are
technically able to grow in the media
and in the environment that we are
setting up the culture so we don't
really able to grow everything and
depending on the specimen depending on
the organism that we're looking for
there is some facilities organisms that
probably are going to be targeting in
some particular areas and also
um there could be some cellular organism
thing that cellular bacteria that would
not want to be able to grow a routine
micro uh media so we can say that one of
the advantages of the ngs is they give
you this broad range of detection that
is go beyond the limitation of the
culture the second one is if we're
talking about organism as fungi's or
even afb
we know that those
those type of culture can take weeks
before we can have a positive growth and
even identification so the other
advantage of having gs especially in afb
and fungi is being able to reduce the
turnaround time or identifying those
organisms and in the case of
fungi especially mold we know the moles
are technically challenging for
identification we need
staff that have
experience and expertise and identifying
microscopically
molds we need to have the environment
for them and the special media so that's
one of the advantage to the ngs is a
gold standard method is an agnostic
method that will be able to provide
identification of any of the mole
present on the sample in a short period
of time without requiring all the
technical expertise that our michael
mycology laboratory can require
thank you
our next question which cpt codes do you
use to bill for ngs based identification
that's a great question um
one of the one of the limitations that
we have right now with
recipe calls and ngs is really there is
no
direct generic cpt code that can be used
some um
ngs
laboratory providers are working
directly with cms to trying to get a
specific cpt call for the platform for
the test that they perform and this is
one of the limitations that is right now
affecting ngs and the whole
implementation especially we see them
from the perspective of an outpatient
settings um and the hospital setting
probably said it'll be different
um based on the the way that hospitals
and tests are actually built um
but from a perspective of a
direct payment for the test using scpd
code that is a lot of limitations that
the sequencing have right now
some sequencing especially 16s can be
provided used using multiplex pcr panel
2 they can be used as part of the
quality control process and this can be
used also as part of a maybe a faster
identification so the most common
pathogen based on the sample
those
normally have cpt code
but the ngs by himself doesn't have
right now
thank you so much and thank you to our
audience for these great questions what
would you recommend as the positive
controls for the assays you described
whole interactive
inactivated bacterial and fungal
organisms in specimen matrix
any other format
well ideally the idea of a quality
control is you're trying to be as close
as possible to match the specimen that
you will be performing um you have a
series of positive controls and some of
them are standardized control especially
those that are known concentration like
we
describe about having high medium low
concentration for positive
control
positive quality control material
if if it's possible use metrics let's
say that you're running a sequencing
from a bronchial lavage and you are able
to use
no matrix to develop those
um
quality control especially for the
extraction portion i think that that
would be ideal the other portion is if
you can use live organism
it could be inactivated organism but
ideally it would be organisms that are
um
they have an entire structure that
haven't been compromised that way we can
evaluate better distraction protocol
that would be the ideal scenario if you
try if you are processing um
a specimen looking for bacteria and
fungi ideally a quality control material
should be able to include or you should
include some of the uh bacteria but also
you can include some of the mold
especially during the extraction
protocol
because we know that they have different
cell walls they have a different
structure
and some of the extraction protocol
needs to continue being oversee and
evaluated during the whole um
analytic analytical process of the
sequencing
thank you so much our next question from
an audience member molecular methods are
incredibly sensitive how do physicians
separate contamination from sample
collections or contamination from
laboratory processing
that's a great question
one of the one of the
way that we can differentiate that is
one is based on the concentration of the
organism oh the actually the dna
observed on the sample that could be a
way to differentiate that but that's a
little difficult one other thing is a
laboratory need to be able to provide a
reliable result so laboratory have a
series of quality control process that
when the result is released
we are
we guarantee that those organisms were
not introduced in the laboratory side
now the other variables that we have is
where they're introduced during the
collection and that's a highly
probability too it's especially it's not
a good quality sample it wasn't
collected with a good technique we are
risking the possibility to be
identifying organisms in the sample that
don't come from the site of infection
and this is probably one of the biggest
areas that um as a microbiologist or
laboratorian especially implementing ngs
we should make
emphasis to clinicians and providers
that the sample collected and submitted
need to be a high quality sample and the
sample need to be collected at the best
technique possible because in a way that
interpretation and the use of that
result for clinical implement clinical
utility or clinical management can be
guaranteed so
the way to eliminate
possible
inclusion of contaminants during the
process is having a robust strong
quality control process and surveillance
processing during the the whole
analytical
pre-analytical and post analytical
but
to avoid the confusion of introducing
contaminants during the collection is
something the laboratory should be able
to provide education and training and
especially a protocol for collection to
provide to um to minimize the risk of
contaminants or inclusion of sometimes
just
colonizing organisms
thank you so much now how do you
identify rna viruses is there a need for
an in ngs for those viruses is the host
response biomarkers are they rna or dna
based
um
we are targeting
technically ribosomal rna genes so in
the case of viruses the ngs using a 16s
or rna
based
ngs is not going to be able to identify
viruses so the best approach in this
scenario if if the idea is to provide a
comprehensive identification that go
beyond bacterias mycobacterias and even
afv but also start introducing
respiratory viruses as many of
our
rna viruses as many of the respiratory
viruses is probably the introduction of
primers and develop a pcr platform in
conjunction with the sequencing um
16s as um
as a sequencing based on on ribosomal
rna
um require amplification this is a
targeted
ngs they amplify this
ribosomal gene from bacteria and fungi
during the process of amplification some
variation of the pcr can be developed
and they can be introduced in targets
primers to target
rna viruses but the sequencing in cells
um the the the genes that are targeted
are are only bacterias and and
mycobacteria
fungi so it's it's not possible to
identify rna viruses using 16s
thank you so much dr alexander and we
have time for a couple more questions
nts has given me a ton of data how do i
as a physician take clinical action
well
one there is a lot of um
perspective they have to be
put together when the
when the result is being evaluated for
for clinical utility um the test
shouldn't be seen just as a result and
none and obviously
the data
and the
and the clinical uh
management of treatment should not be
only based on the ngs result
the clinical presentation of the patient
is one so the symptoms of the patient
how those symptoms actually match with
um the probability of infection and it's
a probability of infection what actually
the ngs results show the other point
important is make use of biomarkers or
just simple indicators of possible
infection um
one of the best example is uh for
example if
people want to do ngs from urine sample
that can be a little messy with all the
organisms but a good collective sample a
catheterized sample or even
yeah a category example
used in conjunction with
uranalysis can provide information
besides the clinical presentation so
this will be um
important variables to take in
consideration the clinical any process
of biomarkers and the result itself now
when we evaluate the result from the
sequencing we need to make sure that the
laboratory is reliable especially the
process is reliable we are not
introducing any contamination during the
process and the laboratory should be
able to provide that a result should not
be released if there is any
concern about contamination and the
other point is the sample itself if the
provided review and the result was the
same provided to collect the sample
is based on the providers on consider if
the sample collector was significant if
the sample collected can actually
have some concern about possibility of
contamination during the collection so
all those variables need to be taken
consideration it's strongly recommended
that only an ngs resolve
is not enough to be able to have a whole
clinic of management on a patient
clinical presentation possibility of
biomarkers and also quality of the
samples should need it should be three
variables to be used in concierge
thank you so much dr alexander we have
time for one more question
this audience member says i would like
to have ngs available to my clinical
staff and laboratory is it viable for a
hospital-based laboratory
i mean it could be viable but one of the
strongest um
i would say barriers but also challenge
the laboratory has is implementation of
a of a
strong database or by a bifurmatic
pipeline i think that's one of the
biggest limitations we have an amazing
platform currently in the market able to
provide sequencing um there is protocol
described and even the company who
provide the the platform the sequencers
are able to provide papers um about
different protocols for
sequencing extraction and sequencing
but one of the biggest limitations is to
have a curated and strong database
that is public database but again that
database needs to be taken very careful
because it's an open
um technically everyone can upload um
sequences as uh to this database that
can be used as a template for
identification if we use a sequence or
we
um
recognize a sequence that is not common
in this database when you have one two
or three sequence and they are poor
quality we could be misidentifying
organisms so
hospitals
i think that at that point when we get
to um the final step of the analytical
process that is the
bioinformatic the data analysis that is
probably the biggest barrier that we
have we need to be able to not only have
molecular technologies or even
microbiologists that work in infection
disease but we should be able to have
a staff that is dedicated to
bioinformatic analysis to be able to
provide statistical analysis and provide
an accurate identification of those
organisms and i think that that's
probably the biggest barrier that we
have but it's possible um the other
opportunity is um
some
agreements or alliance with some company
that can provide the data analysis based
on on a cloud-based platform so the
hospital have all the setup working with
this company when the data can be
submitted to a cloud and the cloud can
send back the result because the
database is performed the analysis you
perform in the cloud with these
companies they actually have curated and
and
review it and very well kept
a databases for the analysis that is
done in the in the local hospital
dr alexander i want to thank you for
your time today would you like to
provide any closing remarks before we go
uh yes so
if one of the important things with ngs
is we know the ngs is
it's a new it's a field that is growing
in infectious disease um
[Music]
it's something that we need to learn
just like we did with we have been doing
good culture with many years
and it's also important to consider that
there is a lot of things that we need to
learn um there is thing that we need to
improve that is areas that we need to
explore we need to find
significance for organism that we've
been seeing now for first time that's
something that the micro lab also
observed when the introduction of the
mould off we were used to we were used
to only base identification on
biochemical reagents and now when we
have the maldital we start seeing new
organisms showing up organism that we
never heard before so the same situation
will happen with ngs we should be
open-minded but in the same time we
should be able to be critical and
rational to trying to explore different
opportunities and see the significance
of those organisms and be able to
collect data and being able to provide
that data to future developed clinical
guidelines
to be able to implement ngs and
laboratory settings
dr alexander again thank you so much for
your presentation today and for
important research and i also want to
thank the lab roots and our sponsor
microgendx for underwriting today's
educational webcast before we go i also
want to thank our audience for joining
us today and for their interesting
questions questions we did not have time
for today and those submitted during the
on-demand period will be addressed by
our speaker via the contact information
you provided at the time of registration
and this webcast can be viewed on demand
laboratories will alert you via email
when it's available for replay we
encourage you to share that email with
your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event until next time take
care everyone bye